just thought it was a coincidence Danny
are you really willing to take the blame
for this
Danny Sullivan is on trial for a serious
crime
he is someone with good intentions but
he is a kid who's lost
Danny is not from a strong background
loser he yearns to be normal like any
teenager but he struggles and he is
suffering and keep your little wiry out
please please
you want to come in clean yourself up
our whole show is a mystery what about
the girl I'm not saying to her either
I'm thinking any after Riot Goodwin is a
professor she's passionate about her job
she's your way into Danny's psyche she's
trying to save his life do you know
where she is Danny I keep telling you I
don't know where she is
there is a twisting tale a psychological
Thriller it's a show like no other I
think these are all victims paradigms
continue to swing back and forth like a
pendulum what do you want me to say that
this whole thing was a setup from the
start what if it was
I hope that people are gripped I hope
that people are shocked he's hiding
something if I'm right Danny may be
innocent Danny where did they all go
[Music]